right absolutely I can't imagine what
it's like to be a woman on the Internet
yeah it's rough sometimes yeah we'll try
to beat a man please so much harder I I
have to be funny and intelligent and
really good-looking woman don't need to
worry about that never I didn't have
someone leave a comment on one of our
videos recently about my glasses not
being good enough for the show wait
about my glasses right now what is
happening it's so hard so hard to be a
man especially in this climate where
we're getting called out for all the
high reject nation I'm Greg Alba Katrina
I want to say Alicia Alicia a lot of
people wanna say Alicia but it's Alicia
I'm so sorry
okay Katrina Elijah is here with us
today to watch another video from looper
it's called Downey junior did not want
to say his final line and end game I've
heard something about this wasn't the
line like men should run the MCU not
Captain Marvel might have been it like
most verbatim I get why he didn't want
to say really hard to be a man in this
day and age really hard for you we made
it work brought it into we brought it in
Robert Downey jr. as I am a man through
a profound journey in Avengers endgame
and delivered an unforgettable line that
was a touching call back to the very
beginning of the Marvel Maggie franchise
as it turns out the iconic moments
almost never happened because Downey jr.
reportedly didn't want to say Tony
Stark's last major line even though co
directors join Anthony Russo lifted the
ban on spoilers for Avengers endgame
we're offering you one last warning
major spoilers ahead and now for the
juicy details during a recent appearance
on cinema plans for your plan to podcast
the Russo brother
opened up about Tony's final scene in
Avengers endgame as you might recall the
hero equipped his own sea with the
Infinity stones snapped his fingers and
promptly turned palace and its minions
into space dust white before Tony
Meredith and says decimation from an
affinity war the mad Titan was clearly
convinced a at the upper hand
proudly proclaiming I'm inevitable
murdered a move displaying all the dry
cool wit that makes Tony who he is he
flashed his hand to show that OC at the
Infinity stones and then he said it I am
Iron Man
of course the line is a callback to the
end of 2008 Iron Man sadly the snap
takes a toll on Tony's body and he dies
shortly after that he manages to speak a
few more words before passing away and
then we get to hear him one more time in
a heartwarming message they recorded
prior to his death but Tony's last big -
as proud assertion of his heroism but
hold everything as Joe and Anthony Russo
tell it
Tony originally didn't say those words
at all in fact he originally didn't say
anything in that moment an early cut of
the film simply had Tony snap his
fingers and that was that enter Avengers
end game editor Jeff fort who pitched
the idea of having Tony say I am Iron
Man
once they heard the concepts the Russo
brothers knew they had to reshoot the
seam of that line included
but apparently Downey jr. was initially
and easy with the idea it took some
convincing before he finally agreed to
do a reshoot that's Jerry Reuss my
dinner with him like two weeks before
we're supposed to shoot it and he's dead
Jerry so it goes on to explain that
producer John Silver it's a close
personal pal of Tony juniors and he just
so happened to be eating with them
according to Joe silver enthusiastically
blurted out what are you
we have to do that once Downey jr. was
on board the crew reportedly headed back
to Juneau to reshoot the scene as we
said before the newly added line servers
are touching nods to the very beginning
of the MCU but the holy shooting process
turned out to be a call back to Tony do
Nia's humble beginnings as Iron Man as
Anthony Russo explains the stage that we
shot that shot was adjacent to the stage
where Robert Downey jr. screen-tested
Wow doesn't give you chills we don't
know what Wow I'd have been worried
about stepping back into character for
the powerful scene but we're so glad he
ultimately came around the final line he
shot is easily one of the most memorable
moments in the entire film and as many
fans can attest Avengers endgame just
wouldn't have been the same without Tony
Stark going out with a bang and the
biting remark that's sort of his calling
card you know check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
exclusive looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
I'm kind of surprised that like they
said they picked the line to the Russos
yeah they were like what it just seems
like it would just make the most sense
out of tano's saying I am inevitable and
inhabited I would have thought that
would have just been a concept that
people had already thought of he's way
down the road yeah it just makes sense
for him to say that at that moment or
I'm trying to just like imagine that
moment without that line yeah just him
staring and doing them just that
wouldn't have been enough for me
what they specify why Downey was opposed
against what they were saying it already
shot the scene and they were done with
it and as technically his I think his
last scene and they he didn't want to
get back into that emotional state is
what he was saying maybe it was like a
little bit like a little selfish of him
because he was just so sad about it
being done yeah I heard Downey was
actually the only one who got to read
the whole script out of all the whole
cash really I think it's because it was
his the time he's gonna die it's they
were like you we gotta run this whole
thing by him to make sure the head of
the MCU all the gay actors started it
all
I love that his final line is I
man so I'd like the tears just came so
strong in that moment when he said that
you know what God means when it's after
that's when a pepper says you can rest
now Oh like watching the reaction of the
other people it could have been a thing
like Deadpool - yes
when Dib feels like monologuing and Evo
yeah you could have been something like
that where he says his whole speech but
what made that powerful was seeing the
effect it had on other people everyone
else especially on pepper it does both
like it brings his character full circle
that line it also is a cool fanservice
moment and I like fanservice when it's
in tune with storytelling yeah as
opposed to just a fanservice I'm just
like full circle for just Ironman but
like full circle for like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in general with
wasn't there and the fact that he did it
on this on the stage where he tested
talk about really giving Danny G or the
feels for that I happen to know a couple
people who actually know Robert Downey G
actually no way not just yeah actually
no out of all the actors I don't know
anyone else who knows any other actors
but I know people who know it's funny
because you watch interviews with him
and he seems like he could probably be
like a cocky guy or something they say
he is like one of the most humble nicest
dudes in the world everything he's went
through like he kind of an addiction and
the alcoholism and all of that and like
going through that downfall and then
growing out of that like you can't help
but be a little bit humble after all of
it you know he overcame so much I love
him I would love to meet him one day
because I'm sure he's like he said the
people who would know him he super sweet
super but the people I know they're very
cocky and they're total [ __ ] hey
Katrina it's that time of the video all
right I would like to have a page of the
dish let's go with a Niraj Krishnan who
is also a supporter of my brother javi
Kawai who you have been on his channel
I know javi yeah he's a he's a fun fella
Niraj he just got a job as an accountant
but as he says here better pay and a
title
what's the title it didn't tell me were
the title is it means he gets an
assistant or an intern to boss around
now no Raj here's what you're gonna want
to do okay in this climate the world we
live in now make sure it's a female
assistant or intern and yes verbally
abusive absolutely as you want what you
want to do right now is take advantage
of the moment and right Josh see it's
always good to have a woman here in the
video with you when you talk about these
things to show all women are an
agreeable I speak for all women that you
should verbally harassed and abused all
Thank You Katrina thank you you're doing
that you're doing a great service to our
country right now so Niraj make sure you
do the right thing and make sure she
doesn't have social media account
because that's the one thing that could
hold you back from having a good you're
lying about boss aroused it's a little
scary subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell follow
Katrina on social media that's the one
that's the one that's it see you guys
you